-Here's how the game works.
James, you're going to
start the game
by pressing "start"
on the buzzer, here,
and then drawing a clue from
the top of the pile.
Get your teammate,
Steve Higgins,
to guess the clue
as quickly as possible,
then hand the buzzer off
to the person on your right.
-Okay.
-To the right
-You can make
any physical gesture,
you can say anything,
but you can't say any word
in the actual clue.
-Can I say words in Spanish?
[ Audience laughing ]
♪♪
-If you're holding the buzzer
when it goes off,
your team loses that round.
First team to win 2 rounds
wins the game.
Let's take our positions.
-Where am I? Over here?
-But what do we win?
What is the prize?
-Uh, you get two tickets
to go to see "Hot Pursuit"
this weekend.
And "The D Train." You get to
go see those two movies.
-Alright. Alright, James.
Here you go. You press start.
-Alright.
-Choose the clue. Good luck.
High five.
[ Laughter ]
-Low five.
-There we go.
-Alright, here we go.
-You guys played a good game.
[ Buzzer beeping ]
-Ready?
-Draw the clue!
-Uh...
This, it's a thing that you hold
the cameras out to take --
-Selfie stick!
-Woo!
-Oh, yeah.
-To the right.
It's on me.
-That's you.
-Yeah, that's me.
Getting all confused.
Ready? Ready? Okay.
It's an insect.
Um...it's red and has
black dots on it.
And it's --
-Una mariquita!
[ Laughter ]
-Judges?
-A ladybug!
-Yes!
-Okay.
[ Singing beat of
"Gangnam Style" ]
♪ Mm-hmm ♪
♪ Oh, sexy lady ♪
[ Singing beat of
"Gangnam Style" ]
-Pitbull?
-No, no, no!
-Who is that?
Psy! Psy sings it!
The only Korean rapper
in the world!
-Uhh!
-That we know of.
[ Laughter ]
-Take up too much time!
-Ahhh!
-A bunch of dudes,
a bunch of criminals are a...
-Okay, that's it.
Too much time.
[ Buzzer ]
-Pass!
-Ohh!
-"Gangnam Style."
-"Gangnam Style!"
Song title.
-Oh, yeah, we got one!
See, isn't this game fun?
-Is that a tie?
-No, it's not.
Right now. Here we go, man.
-Okay, focus!
-One-nothing! Here we go!
-I push and then what?
-Push, then grab, then pull.
-Pull!
-Push, then grab.
No, here we go.
-Ehh...
What are you sleeping in.
[ Laughter ]
What are you --
my outfit for sleeping.
-Your outfit for sleeping?
-Yes.
-Uh, flannel pajamas?
-No. No.
Think. Look at me.
-Ohh.
-Uh, uh...lingerie?
-No, better than that!
Less than that!
It's like a...
Whatever, it's two words.
-Teddy?
-No! Like, they also say it
when you give birth.
A woman gives birth.
When you are born.
When you're born!
-When I'm born!
When you're born, you, uh...
-What do you wear
when you're born?
-Nothing!
Oh, sleep in the nude!
-No!
-Naked!
-Nothing. Oh, a diaper!
-No!
[ Buzzer ]
-Birthday suit!
-Ohhh.
-I am not playing
with you anymore.
-I mean, what are
you talking about?
-How could you not get --
-It was the most confusing clue!
-What could be more easy
than I said,
"What are you sleeping in?"
"The day I give birth."
-How about "Happy blank?"
-No, because you cannot
say the word, right?
-Well, then say, "Feliz blank."
[ Laughter ]
Your turn!
-Here we go!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Alright.
It's alright.
-Ohh.
-Uhh.
I have a sense about this.
I have a bad feeling.
-Bad feeling!
-It's in my stomach, though.
-Gut. Gut feeling.
-Yes!
-Alright.
-You're good.
-Here we go!
-Ready? Ready?
-[ As Arnold Schwarzenegger ]
I'll be back.
-Arnold Schwarzenegger.
-Yeah.
-"Terminator!"
-Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh!
It's not June rain
brings August --
-Flowers.
-Yeah, but what's the phrase?
-April flowers...
-April -- April --
-April showers bring
May flowers!
-Yes!
-Focus!
-I am focused!
Stop saying that.
-Okay.
What the girls
in America go --
[ Laughter ]
Okay. So they're thirsty.
-Yeah.
-After work, and they don't want
to pay for their drinks.
-Yeah, yeah. Uh...Happy Hour!
-Yes!
[ Buzzer ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Buzzer dings ]
-We won! We won!
That was the best!
That was last-minute!
It was the best ever!
Our thanks to Sofia Vergara,
the champion!
James Marsden right there.
-Here's how this is
gonna work, okay?
-Okay.
-Alright.
Will, you're gonna
start the game
by pressing "start"
on this buzzer, here.
-Yes.
-Okay.
Then drawing a clue from
the top of the pile.
-Yes.
-Get your teammate Tariq --
-Tariq, my teammate.
-To guess the clue as quickly
as possible.
-Philly in the building.
[ Applause ]
-Jersey in the building.
-Come on, we got it.
We can do this
I'm already feeling we got this.
Don't let him intimidate you.
Yeah, he's good.
-Don't be scurred.
-I'm not scared.
-No one here is scurred.
[ Laughter ]
I was scurred at one point.
-Scurred.
-Then I go, "Oh, there's nothing
to be scurred about."
You know? I was like,
"This is fun."
Then once you get it right, you
hand the buzzer to your right.
-Okay, let's go, alright?
-Are we gonna stand in a line?
No.
-No.
-No, right here. I'll go here.
Will. Kirsten, you go there.
Tariq there.
-Okay.
-Alright, here we go.
First to win two rounds.
-Oh, okay.
-Whatever.
-That was so bad.
He has a disability, so...
Maybe we get an extra point.
-That was so white of us,
right there.
We're perfect.
We couldn't even slap five.
That was really awkward.
I didn't know if we were
going for fists or grabbing.
I almost grabbed your fist
at one point.
Go, "Yeah! We got it."
First, here we go.
Will, press start and then
draw your clue.
Thank you so much for playing.
-Press start, draw my clue.
-Press this, pick that.
-Good luck.
-Are we ready?
Good luck to everyone.
-Yes, good luck to everybody.
-It's happening! We're going.
[ Timer beeps ]
-I pressed it.
Oh. Uh...
Around your waist.
You wear -- with the --
You put stuff in it.
-Holster. Fanny pack.
-Yup. There we go.
-Holster?
-Philly, that's rights.
Holster.
-It's not South,
but it's where Santa lives.
-North Pole!
[ Beeping ]
-He's not the person
making the car go forward,
but he talks like he is.
He would like to be,
but he's not in the front.
-The navigator.
-He's not in the front!
-He's in the back.
-Right, and he is...
-He's --
He's driving in the back.
-Yeah, okay.
So what is that person?
-What is that person?
Backseat driver!
-Yes! Yes!
-No!
-Go!
-Okay, uhh.
It's a type of hula thing,
but it's only from here to here.
-Belly -- torso --
mid -- belly button?
Midriff?
-But if you're --
did I say the word?
-Belly button?
[ Buzzer ]
-Yeah!
-Woo-hoo!
-So close. Belly dancer.
-What was it? Oh.
-Belly dancer!
-Did I say "hula dancer?"
-You said hula dancer.
-Midriff, what the --
-Well, from here to here.
-She said midriff.
I didn't say midriff.
-You said hula middle belly.
-I didn't do "middle belly."
I didn't say that at all.
-Alright, so they won one.
-They won one.
-Big deal.
-Alright, here we go.
-Yeah, alright. Yeah.
This is the big comeback.
-Hula middle-belly.
Hula middle-belly.
-No one said
"hula middle-belly."
-Hula middle-belly!
-No one said that at all.
Ready? Here we go.
[ Timer beeps ]
[ Beatboxing ]
-Beatbox?
[ Timer thuds ]
-What's up, Will Smith?
-Uh-uh.
-Me and Carlton were
from there.
-Bel-Air.
-Yep.
[ Applause ]
-[ Imitating drumroll ]
-Drumroll! Drumroll!
-[ As Sylvester Stallone ]
Adrian!
-Rocky!
-No, who played him?
-Sylvester Stallone!
-Correct.
-Ahh-ooh-ga.
An old-timey car horn.
Don't make me open up a --
-Can of whoop-ass?
-Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Star Wars. [ Growling ]
-Darth Vader.
-Yep.
-Uh. Uh...
What is that?
[ Applause ]
Oh, let me pick this up
because I just --
-Name dropper! Name dropper!
[ Beeping quickly ]
-Uh, um...
You send this when you've had --
[ Buzzer ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's right!
I love that you got
"can of whoop-ass."
No matter what happens,
you know me.
Don't make me open up
a can of whoop-ass.
-She just got
"can of whoop-ass."
That was hardcore.
-Alright, guys, whoever wins
the next round is the winner.
And thank you all for playing.
Tariq, you start it off.
Here we go.
[ Timer beeps ]
[ Chuckles ]
Can of whoop-ass.
-You can't really say it,
because it's complicated.
It messes with your mouth.
-Tongue twister.
-Yes.
-Alright. He's a cartoon.
It sells chicken.
-It's a chicken cartoon?
-It's a chicken restaurant.
-A chicken restaurant?
-Olive Oyl.
-Popeye!
-Yeah!
-Popeye's.
-Yeah.
-It's the last day of the week.
-Friday.
-Yes.
-TGIF.
-Yes. What are the words?
-"Thank God It's Friday."
-Oh, my goodness. You're good!
-I can't walk because I have --
-Broken leg.
-No, I have --
-You can't -- you have two --
You can't walk because
you have high heels.
-No.
You have sore feet!
-I can't walk 'cause I have --
-You have tight pants?
[ Laughter ]
-You have two...
You're paralyzed.
-What's this?
-Your foot.
-Yeah. I have.
-Two left feet!
-Ahh!
[ Buzzer ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Buzzer dings ]
-That's the strategy,
right there!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thanks to Will Smith,
Kirsten Dunst, Tariq Trotter!